so the vancouver titans were once
considered one of the best teams in the
overwatch league the all korean lineup
won 19 straight games eventually losing
to the san francisco shock in the
overwatch league grand finals but
recently the entire roster was dropped
the organ plotted overnight and now
vancouver is scrambling for a fix so
what happens one of the most beloved
teams to ever play the game
[Music]
man Keith I have to thank you for giving
me a heads up on grub hubs contact free
delivery I've been using it almost every
day it's super safe and it's actually
really easy to use man I'm at least a
little bit relieved to hear that I was
actually pretty worried about all the
instant noodles you were eating dude was
getting rough there for a second my mom
was calling me it was a whole thing but
it doesn't matter because with our
current shelter-in-place guidelines it's
never been more important to support our
favorite restaurants which is super easy
to do with grub hubs daily perks wait
what do you mean by daily perks dude it
is fantastic every day you get $10 off
an order of $30 or more unselected
restaurants which means I get food
delivered safely to my door while also
getting to support my favorite spots and
that sounds dope but dude you gotta be
honest have you ordered anything other
than ramen listen man I don't want to
talk about it anymore
ramen does not matter let's just move on
with the story okay now the overwatch
community knew something weird was going
on when on April 19th most of the Titans
players removed all of the branding from
their social media and on April 30th we
got confirmation that things were
seriously wrong when Superstar off tank
Jan you and head coach spaz on left the
team then on May 4th coach andante left
the team and it only seems like a matter
of time before the rest of the dominoes
fell which is exactly what happened two
days later on May 6th when the overwatch
league announced that the rest of the
roster was being released effective
immediately the statement talks about
how do two kovin the players returned
home to Korea where they were supposed
to play a modified season online in the
asia-pacific division now this was a
drastic change in terms of how the
players in the org were going to
communicate
since Vancouver didn't have anyone on
the ground in Korea to help them get
things running our initial plan was for
the team to join the Asian division and
continue to play the new schedule from
the comfort of players homes but it was
quickly apparent that this created a
whole new set of challenges the time
difference made it difficult from
management and the home fan base to
connect with the team and technical
challenges for the players playing from
home further exacerbated this situation
on top of that the living and playing
conditions allegedly weren't up to
standards and apparently the Vancouver
management
want to spend more money to upgrade so
the decision was made to release the
rest of the roster the time players
wanted better resources in Korea the
nuts organization that owns the Valkyrie
Titans were basically like you have to
deal with it if you want to go home we
allowed you to go home you have to deal
with it this way which led to this weird
standoff very awkward situation and just
like a lot of things if overwatch leave
the season it was really awkward
it was very sloppy and it's ending in a
mess well this news certainly rocked the
overwatch community rumors had been
circulating for a while that things
weren't good in Vancouver long before
kovin aidid but in order to make sense
of what's happened here we need to step
back just a bit and take a look at the
overwatch league itself now if you look
at eSports like csgo League of Legends
dota
hell even rocket League the biggest
markets in some of the best talent are
found in Europe Korea and China and it's
no different when it comes to overwatch
in the early days of competition dating
back to 2016 korean overwatch
specifically apex was as good as a god
and run away were one of the most
popular teams that competed from the
colorful pink jerseys the grassroots
story of an owner trying to make a dream
come true to the bond the players had
with each other
the fans absolutely loved would run away
represented I can't believe it run away
coming in on paper
oh my such an underdog in the semi-final
and they will win it 3-2
runaways go into the semi-finals and
brother he starts riding he is reaching
boy haha now imagine it's 2018 and
you're an investor looking to buy an
eSports team the overwatch League is
expanding so you decide to spend a
report of 30-something million dollars
to get on board which is exactly what
the a Collini group did they would
eventually by the vancouver titans slot
in the league and then they went looking
for a roster now you think they'd
realize that in this extremely global
game that hey if we pick up a
korean-speaking roster communication is
gonna be super important if we want to
succeed
that was the twenty teams that competed
in the overwatch league season two only
six had less than three Korean players
on its rosters so I mean if you want to
have an overwatch league team odds are
you're probably gonna have to deal with
international talent which makes it all
the more confusing because communication
was by far the biggest obstacle the team
faced and it ultimately led to the
release of one of the most talented
overwatch teams we've ever seen and we
know it was one of their biggest
problems because Alfred devera who runs
the eSports side of that business said
as much in an interview with Sports Net
quote I think for us these guys didn't
speak English and we didn't speak Korean
we had a translator that we hired on in
the season of last year he was in place
as of June of last year so there were
mistakes made for sure if I could do it
over again it would probably be in
everyone's best interests if just to
ease with the cultural assimilation on
both sides just to have perhaps English
lessons for the players and Korean
lessons for our staff end quote
okay so the Aquilani group picks up the
runaway roster and they become the
Vancouver Titans just in time for season
two of the overwatch League and pretty
much right away these dudes are on fire
yeah domino gets to its three the whole
hog of bore cake make it a 5k everyone
they win 19 games in a row the team
knows each other really well things are
looking great
but a season two continued through the
third and fourth splits rumors started
to pop up according to a report from
kotaku the players were allegedly
unhappy with their contracts and
communication was pretty spotty
apparently the players would go up to a
month without hearing back from
management imagine how tough this
situation was for the players not only
do you have to compete at the highest
level of your game you're living in an
entirely new country you don't know
anyone outside of your teammates and
immediate staff and you rarely hear back
from the people that signed you in the
first place the entire run of the
vancouver titans seems like a series of
fumbles and missed opportunities
starting with creating a tangible
identity for the team if you look at the
new york excelsior as a comparison
here's an entirely Korean speaking
roster that came right out of the gate
trying to build something fans could
love they had translated interviews held
they had an hour-long documentary
helping you get to know the players this
behind-the-scenes look will give you
unprecedented access inside the workings
of the team and how they grew from
middle-of-the-pack to having the best
record in the overwatch league Vancouver
had none of that despite having one of
the most beloved rosters and loyal fan
bases in all of overwatch history and
that is how this fell apart last week
the Vancouver Titans picked up an
entirely new roster days after
announcing the release of the old squad
and now the organization has to rebuild
entirely on the fly and try to find a
way to compete against the overwatch
league's best teams
and that new roster was tested
immediately as they lost to Ceres over
the weekend losing to the Washington
Justice and the Florida mayhem now let's
be honest it's been a rough few months
for overwatch first Sinatra one of the
most popular players in the overwatch
league left for valor in late April and
now you have one of the most beloved
rosters in the league with no home the
overwatch League is dying has become a
bit of a meme at this point but with
this recent news the fact that other
contender Series teams are folding and
the fact that other talented pros like
World Cup winner Corey are leaving
4-valent it's hard to deny that the
overwatch League feels like it's in a
bit of a freefall okay I got clapped for
a while no just gonna admit that there's
no denying it what really pissed me off
and kind of gave me that spark was the
fact that they were like over/under
Devin can't get 10 kills we'll give him
a beer if he doesn't he owes us beer if
I don't and I just got I got very angry
even though I was still like happy on
stream I'm like y'all want to tell me
alright and then I popped off I had like
22 kills so now everyone owes me beer
and it's fantastic